let me tell you something
if tomorrow wasn't promise what would
you get for today
forget everything else
forget everything else
forget that there was any sunlight left
what would you spend today
thinking about
yourself
or the man that's beside you
or the man that you know you'll get
everything in your heart for
we get one opportunity in their life
One Chance in life
do whatever you're gonna do
to lay your foundation to make whatever
more you're gonna make
whatever Legacy You're Gonna Leave
your legacy
and it's found through ever
wins and losses come a dime of dust
the effort nobody can judge after
because effort is between you and
everything got nothing to do with nobody
else
so that team that think they're ready to
see you
they think what they seen on film
they show it film shows
because every day is a new day
every moment is a new moment
so now you got to go out and show them
that I'm a different creature now
than I was five minutes ago
because I pissed off for greatness
cause if you ain't pissed off for
greatness that means you're okay with
being mediocre
and I always say you show me a crowd
I'll show you your future
it's it's simple right there's three
type of people you need in your life
you need the inspire
the excited and the grateful
every one of them you will need for the
rest of your life
but your your biggest your biggest
distraction is
tell me what your foundation is
where do you go when you need peace
so now you sit here and tell me you
don't know what to do you know what to
do
but the people you're around ain't doing
what you're supposed to be doing
I'm begging you man I'm begging you from
a man to a man
let go
let go
let go of these people who you know
aren't for you
I don't care how fast and how you jump
sooner or later you don't have nothing
to fall back on my man
it's like a house built on sand
as soon as the wind and the water come
by it's gone
that's where your dreams go
there's not a person on my team in 16
years
that is consistently beat me to the ball
every play that ain't got nothing to do
with Talent
because it's got everything to do with
effort
nothing else
15 straight years
12 Pro bowls later
if you want numbers
I done saw all of them
and the only thing that's kept me around
is my effort
so when you put on this
all I ever knew
because I won the number one recruit I
won the number one linebacker I wasn't
even in the media guy all I ever knew
what effort will get me seen on tape
effort will get me noticed to get to the
lead effort would one day take care my
mom and my kids
effort which is between you and you
nobody else can give you effort
effort is with Inside Man
there's two sides of pain that I don't
think a lot of people really understand
right there's one side of pain that's
the suffering and the discomfort side of
pain that's why everybody raised their
hands when I first asked do you have
everybody ever been through pain because
that hurts you remember what that felt
like
but then there's another sign of pain
that's called effort
it's called Glory
it's called if you can find a way to
push through pain there's something
greater on the other side of it
and if you never tap into it
because the first time you felt that you
backed off
first time you fell ah that burned the
first time you fell it's too much
and we rationalize with ourselves to
where we automatically stop
that's why a bunch of us give up so much
in life so quickly
it's why kids
have a problem finishing things in
today's time
because as soon as they feel a small bit
of discomfort of things they write oh
they're gone
I can't do it no more
suppose I told you
the greatest pain of my life
is the reason I'm standing here today
suppose I was able to share with you
my routine was so crazy man I was seeing
almost nine doctors for nine weeks
six A.M
everyone 10 days
from tricep repair surgery
had my bike flew out I flew my bike out
I got on my bicycle I cycle a lot I got
on my cycle I got on my bike and I tried
to grip the bar
and I couldn't grip it
didn't have enough strength
and I sat there for 30 minutes
it's all made up in my mind
it's crying
and grip the handlebars
just grab the ball
see sometimes we think the pain is what
controls us is what's actually our
subconscious mind
that if we ever tapped into that that's
what dictates most of our lives
and I'm sitting there and I say just
squeeze it
and I squeezed it
ten days out
and I started riding a bike 10 days out
because see pain pain is tricky
because if you don't control pain
it'll control you
I want you to research the story of
Blake David and Goliath
I want you to understand what the king
told David when he put on the armor on
David and he said I want you to fight
Goliath with this armor because he's
huge he's nine foot tall and David said
something that was very key
to the king he said King I can't fight
you'll fight I got to fight my fight
2005 I had one of the most tragic
injuries ever
and I couldn't help my team
so the leader was took away so there
could be doubt
but if you still have a leader
and Joe Flacco you got to Rally around
behind him and it ain't about wins the
losses it's about lawyers it's about
understanding imma make the play or I'ma
watch the play be made
it's simple
let's see if I can tell my safety you
cover this cause I'm gone this time
it's a man on a man every time you play
the game it'll never change it's about
winning one-on-one battles
fight some fight
this I will fight the fight
one in six doesn't Define who you are
what defines who you are is what you do
when you wanted six
not the man you will fight for just
everything you got today not because of
the snowboard
but because when this thing ends you
have a brother to call for life as long
as you take everything you have
if the lion is the king of the jungle
how can he be the king of the jungle
if he's not the biggest
the elephant is probably one of the
biggest
he can't be the fastest because that's a
cheetah
he can't be the smartest
so he's not the biggest the fastest or
the smartest
so how does a lion
become the king of the jungle
it's mentality
that's the only difference of a lion and
an elephant
when a lion walks up and sees an
elephant he thinks lunch
uh elephant things run
and it's all mentality because when a
male lion walks up he may be outnumbered
by a pack of hyenas
but I'm King
of my jungle because of my mentality
[Music]